this is screen junkies movie fight
brought to you by Squarespace now your
host Andy
signor hey screen junkies welcome to
another episode of movie fights as you
may have figured out by now I am not
Andy signor I am Spencer J Gilbert but
Andy signor is sitting across from me
hey guys yeah why well we all saw
Jurassic world this week and Andy and
Dan felt so strongly about it that they
had to Andy had to put down the gavl and
step into the ring himself are you ready
for it I had to do it yeah I had to take
this man down but you've been talking
about it for a while but that's not the
only fight we have uh we got more than
Jurassic world we've got fights on the
Daredevil casting news we've got the
best movie poster of all time and so
much more but if you guys aren't into
any one of those fights don't go it's
Sunday kick back click the pick your
fight button and choose a fight that you
think would be more interesting to you
so please subscribe to movie fights on
iTunes uh the link is in the description
below you can get all the joy of this
fine program without having to look at
our faces speaking of which let's
introduce our
Fighters today's Fighters are Mike
Carlson actor and comedian three wins
three
losses Andy sigor creator of honest
trailers zero wins two losses Dan Merl
undefeated movie fights Champion eight
wins yeah yeah what a rocket oh man what
an awesome lineup we have here some Old
Ranch Andy so welcome you're the care
trailers and you're here to fight I I'm
here to fight uh I had to fight this
week Dan and all we all saw this movie
and Dan and I were just fighting so much
at the end of the movie it was awful I
needed to go home and you wouldn't shut
up that we were like we have to save
this and we have to do it here because
this is what this is about that's what
it's all about I'm very excited is
polarized immature opinions screaming at
each other Carlson welcome back to the
show thank you for having me uh I saw
Jurassic world last night uh very late
I'm very tired but I'm ready to be in
between the two of you as you yell this
is no place for nuance Dan Merl the
champ putting his not putting the belt
on the line no just just my pride just
the pride and that spotless record and
the Spotless record you put that in my
hands very brave of you of course and um
yeah we we'll see what happens uh since
Dan is up here can't forget on The Dan
cam is show producer Jason welcome I'm
very excited to look up facts about
dinosaurs and random merchandise of
Jurassic world yeah # manam welcome to
the show oh
manam uh so also another thing before we
get started we have some amazing pieces
of fan art to Showcase if we can bring
those up here on the
screen Isn't that cool so these are two
illustrations by Matt Lewis at filosi um
that one looks to be anyone who's anyone
on movie fights and I think there's
another one there yeah
a that's my and that I believe is Andy's
pronunciation of Spectre the new movie
called Spectra Spectra it's a it's
special executive for Counter
Intelligence terrorism revenge and
extortion not extortion and revenge so
the more you know I like seeing the fan
art cuz it's like you can tell who likes
Roger bar or who likes me cuz us one of
the two of us are in guys in in the
swing spots yeah uh so just a reminder
how this show goes uh you were not being
scored on your picks you were being
scored on your arguments on the facts
you bring to the table on your passion
your creativity your cor Zone the skill
of your rhetoric that is what you are
scored on not whether I like the movie
or not finally before we get started
started we wouldd like to thank our
sponsors at Squarespace if you've been
waiting to build a website that looks
professionally designed with no coding
experience required look no further than
Squarespace whether you're as smart as
Tony Stark or as technologically out of
touch as Captain America Squarespace
gives you the tools you need to build a
secure stable website that you'll be
proud to post your angry open letters to
Jos Weeden on that's why it's trusted by
millions of people including some of the
world's biggest brands Click The
annotation or go to squarespace.com
backov fights and save 10% off a new
subscription by using the code movie
fights and if you're still not convinced
you can also try Squarespace for free no
credit card required Square Squarespace
build it beautiful good job Spencer I've
used Squarespace super easy to make a
website it's actually pretty fun I'm
using it immediately after the show
Spencer J gilbert.com is a picture of a
horse so I really need to step my game
up sometimes that's important wait it's
actually a picture of a horse yeah I
need to really do a lot of work I'm just
parking the domain for now just parking
it is it your horse not necessarily all
right so with that out of the way let's
get this fight going now let's do this
this is where we
fight fight fight all right oh my God
you guys have been preparing ever since
the Jurassic World trailer came out and
we're finally here uh now because Mike
uh you and I are kind of in the middle
on this one um to put our cards on the
table and these guys are so passionate
we are giving you the opportunity to
instead of fight uh be caught in this
melstrom
to to pick who you think is going to win
and get a point if you are correct so
are you willing to do that today I am
willing to do that yes do you want me to
write this in a secret ballot please
write that down hand it to me I will
hold on to it until the decision has
been made
you will receive a point and for the
record he knows I I liked it Dan did not
like it and just for so my card's on the
table I'm somewhere in the middle I
think that you can have a nuanced
opinion about movies but that's that's
just not going to happen today I want to
just say this my my opinion is very
nuanced this paper is see-through so be
careful I'm not looking surpr can I take
a fresh piece of paper for someone's
thing so with that I'm actually going to
time this one cuz I have a feeling it
could go half an hour or longer that's
generous half an hour are going to have
our opening statements we will begin
with
Andy round one here it is so look
Jurassic world it's not a perfect movie
it's not an Oscar movie it's a fun movie
and the question that come up that came
up and that we're fighting right now is
fun or failure thank you Andy this is
not a failure if anything this is an
amazing achievement that they made a
decent sequel to Jurassic Park finally
and the reason why it was decent is
because it was fun as hell can we tear
apart some things can we poke holes at
the characters a bit of course we can
but that doesn't take away that I felt
like a 13-year-old kid watching that
movie and when I left and I have so much
more to get into but I wanted to stand
right there and let Mr Merl do his
opening and I will bring back opening
stat I will bring back my points as to
why this was an extremely fun movie Dan
you're autal uh I have an opening
statement as well but it's not for me
it's from an old friend of ours these
words were originally directed at the
creator of uh the park in question I
direct these words toward the creators
of this movie hit it jte I'll tell you
the problem with the scientific power
that you're that you're using here uh it
didn't require any discipline to attain
it you stood on the shoulders of
geniuses uh to accomplish something as
fast as you could and before you even
knew what you had you you patented it
and packaged it and SLA it on lunch box
and now you're selling it you want to
sell it
well so what Jurassic world is true
words this is a
product it's not a movie it was much
like the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park
cooked up in a lab by people who wanted
to get a lot of people to show up and
pay a lot of money to make the investors
happy and it's a failure because it
doesn't attempt to be a movie in any
sense of the word and in the fact that
other than the fact that it had some
dinosaurs in it which is the bare
minimum and again I have so much I can
go into Mike by the way since you're
going to be sitting here have some
Jurassic Park officially licensed fruit
snacks while you wait I love this world
I have a whole thing but I want to jump
into what he said like of course it's
it's a it's a it's a studio movie that
needs to make its money back but you're
wrong Colin tavaro isn't a mass massive
massive fan of these films and you can
see it in the movie you can see the
movie that him and his partner took the
time to actually try and do it now I
agree there are F faults in this movie
that I'm sure were because of the
money-making Studio machine but my God
Kudos that he was able to stand at the
end of this tall by being a first time s
Blockbuster director and pull what he
did now I I just don't I don't agree
with you that it was made to just made
money like of course every movie needs
to you can't make a movie of this size
without thinking of the four quadrants
and this is a perfect four quadrant
Blockbuster popcorn Thriller that's what
it is we can't you can't deny that
that's what it was made for and there
are so many worse ones out there that to
make this be the failure when this one
had a ton of fun so let me get
specifically the fun I was going to say
you guys are circling each other let's
get I want to get to the fun so the fun
the plot is smart the plot is different
than the first two sequels the first two
sequels are complete terrible retreads
of what we've already seen before now
you can of course every ret Jurassic
Park is going to be running away from
dinosaurs what else do you there's not
much else you can do it is it is what it
is and we'll get to we're going to pitch
our our Dream sequel later but in this
park we went to later we've make the
pack uh the park active Spectators I
like this whole plot they did The
Spectators are bored they even said
today's generation the living breathing
dinosaur is no exciting than no more EX
than an elephant I believe that that is
true I think if dinosaurs had been
around for 30 years our cell phone
obsessed cynical culture would be bored
of them and so you the DNA splicing I
liked it that's how the movie is built
off of a BS science that we were like
okay we believed you got to go from it
and make it more interesting and they
were able to because they said in one
they spliced the D they it wasn't pure
dinos they had to put other you know Mr
DNA taught us they had to put other
pieces in there to make it true so
that's not that far far off from what
they were doing and to me the splicing
was great because if you ask any
13-year-old kid which I felt which two
dinosaurs do you want to see mixed it's
a raptor and a T-Rex like of course I
want to see those two mix it makes the
T-Rex faster more exciting scarier
smarter all those things that make it
happen so Andy says the plot is smart
Dan you're rebuttal the plot was not
smart in any way shape or form the
indominous Rex our new dinosaur uh it
could have should have been called the
plotosaurus Rex because it did whatever
the plot required it to do in any given
moment could it did it need to CL
camouflage itself yeah and then we cut
to Dr R oh yeah some C cuttlefish DNA
and then it needed to be cold blooded to
escape its pen oh yeah no we threw in
some some amphibians or some I don't
know whatever and then when it needed to
be a raptor so it could God help us talk
to the other Raptors then all of a
sudden it's part Raptor here's what this
movie's got going for it I'm going back
to your opening argument which is there
are some key words decent the best
sequel It's a four quadrant it made you
feel like a 13y old do you agree with
those is that no is that the bar that's
the bar that we have to clear now just
to be clear you don't agree that it's
the best Jurassic Park sequel I'm saying
I'm saying that that's that's that's a
justification you're you're you yourself
said oh we can pick apart this movie we
we can we can pick apart the plot we can
pick this apart then why is this the
movie that we're not doing that on we do
that we have not given there's so many
other movies that we don't give this
kind of slack too what specifically in
this movie made you say you know what
I'm going to ignore it for this movie
it's the same reason my 10-year-old
nephew who left the movie Delirious last
night was cuz it was fun as hell like
Transformers aren't that's not fun
Transformers has every problem you're
saying but even the action is confusing
like that is a byproduct of a lazy
filmmaker does nothing I thought they
made smart smarter decisions than this
one it's not a perfect movie of course
it's not it's a it's a blockbuster there
when you have a blockbuster you have to
sometimes fast forward through some
character arcs that you might otherwise
want to tell but kids don't want to see
dawn of the plan of the Apes like kids
don't want to see Inception like kids
want to see a fun movie this was a fun
movie now we can go through the things
but the dinosaurs in this movie that was
one of your biggest complaints earlier
like oh they're all CGI blah blah blah
the dinosaurs were not the problem in
this movie the dinosaurs were pretty fun
the dinosaurs looked uh they even had
the animatronic dinosaur when it died
that was a really cool throwback scene
there were so many cool Throwbacks that
actually whether it was a trick or not
was the reason why was also fun to me
because seeing them talk about the old
park and how it was cooler it was a self
reference thing that made it sort of
made it okay in my eyes where they were
at least acknowledging we know guys this
isn't going to be as good as you can't
make a movie as good as the original and
make a sequel Jurassic Park you just
can't do it that's my biggest point of
contention yes you can if you try what
if George what What if after Star Wars
they'd said you know what you cannot
make a movie as good as Star Wars Star
Wars had a huge
Universe about dinosaurs in Amusement
part and that's the story about space
laser sword and spaceships What if after
Star Wars they'd said you know what you
can't make a movie that good so let's
just do another movie whatever we'll
throw in some characters in Space
Battles and kids will love it and it'll
be a hit and 13-year-olds will have fun
with it and it'll be fine no what what
I'm saying and again my my my my let me
talk can I have another food snack yes
of they look delicious my my job in this
fight is to argue for why this movie is
a failure and I'm saying it's a failure
because it never tried to be a good
movie for me when a what a movie fails
is when it doesn't put forth any effort
whatsoever to try to be good and it
didn't the plot was terrible the
characters were completely how was the
action the the the action how was the
action be honest it was it was CG Dinos
from the beginning of this from the
first trailer I said this is going to be
a big dumb summer runaway from Dinosaurs
movie and that's exactly what it was
we've seen these dinosaurs before he
asked you the question I want to ask you
too what's the best Jurassic Park
sequel what what's the best Jurassic
Park this one is up there probably with
Lost World we're not argu we're not no
no no we're not arguing best Jurassic
Park sequel because none of them have
been good but we're arguing fun or
failure but will you let me argue
failure I'm trying to but I'm just
trying to understand if this is a better
sequel than the others how can that be a
failure because the other one sucked and
this one sucked too Dan what I'd like to
hear from you is why this movie isn't
Fun why this movie isn't fun because it
offers nothing new and for me and for me
a movie that's fun is one that I
remember is one that I get invested in I
never once feared for any of these
characters I never once got invested in
the plot for me when you go when you
have real fun there's a difference
between being diverted and and having
fun having fun is when you're into the
movie you're rooting for the characters
you think one of them might die they
don't die yeah there's a big cheer
moment it's not just throwing dinosaurs
up on the screen and going whoa that's a
fireworks show it's it's it it it bursts
for a second and then it's gone and it's
immediately forgotten and can what was
Chris's character's name I want to
respond The Fear Part you said because
this movie probably had the most death
of any of them but they were but they
were completely random characters that
you didn't care about but I dare you to
not tell me that scene when the
assistant is picked up by the
pterodactyl and then thrown around with
the pterodactyls and then eaten by the
big fish that was so fun and violent and
I did not see that coming and that was a
surprise and it was fun I could turn on
the Sci-Fi channel and watch that any
day I I was watching that and I'm like
this is a scene from a Sci-Fi Channel
original movie I saw a movie on Sci-fi
channel where Tiffany from the 0s was
the star of it and she got eaten by a
dinosaur I bet you didn't look as good
as that did and I will say the Jurassic
Rene looked a little better but you can
you could knock you could knock a $100
million off the budget of this movie
same script call it escape from Dinosaur
Island and it would be a Sci-Fi Channel
original movie and no one would know the
difference so here's another thing you
said they didn't try I disagree I think
the Raptor training which everyone has
the problem with it's a little silly I
get it but it's also it's not that
farfetched the alpha part that they
introduced in the plot was a cool idea
do I wear wish Chris Pratt had a little
bit more history or a moment where we
believed it a little bit more sure but
was it still good enough that I was like
I believe it I'm having fun with this
that switch when the indominous Rex
talks to it and you realize oh [__] the
G that's why they didn't tell us what's
in it's Raptor today I clapped out loud
I was like that is a super fun moment
and surprise and then the Raptors turned
and took him out and started eating his
crew that's what a raptor does that was
a fun twist that was a fun moment even
the GoPro when you're running the around
and it's like yes there are people in
Jeopardy we've seen it before but they
did new things with it I saw it in new
ways and it did surprise me I thought
that was a really fun idea that wasn't
lazy that was someone in a room Colin
and his partner I can't remember it was
like trying their best to put some fun
and some originality into the
Blockbuster machine and I applaud him
for trying unlike two and three which
were complete failures to me this is
totally a passing grade it's totally a
passing grade and not a failure you
can't I mean it's just the the the
action scene alone at the end the finale
with the Raptors and the T-Rex it's like
you're either in you're out and if
you're in it's fun it's totally fun you
can't I even saw you sort of shrugging
your shoulders as the Raptor joins the
fight yes but it's like I was I I was
completely on board and that's exactly
what I wanted and that's exactly what I
wanted out of the other two sequels that
they never gave me and in part two the
rap I well but in part two the Raptors
are doing the Benny Hill routine whereas
this one we've trained them but then
they go against us and it just so much
smarter they have GoPros um Dani you're
Rob at least they didn't put it on
themselves again the qu the qualifi the
qualifiers that I'm getting good enough
trying their best if you're in it's
like again as Hal said when we were
doing The Hobbit thing even a man in
jail can smile once in a while it's not
like I sat there through the entire
movie with a dow look on my face
obviously when there are dinosaurs
running around on screen you're going to
raise your eyebrows every once in a
while but again my point here is that
this movie is a failure because it was
not there there's failures and there's
Noble failures it's it's not like they
tried something amazing and it it just
didn't quite work the the characters
just didn't quite click or there was
just something that didn't quite come
together there was not one character or
line of dialogue in this movie that was
made to be memorable it wasn't intended
to be anything but the bare minimum of a
what a summer blockbuster can be can you
name one character from the movie Owen
uh was was Chris Pratt's character
that's one
right there's one I don't but I don't I
the names of the characters in the first
one I don't remember the kids names you
don't remember Tim and Lex no I don't
really you're telling me the jurass
remember Tim and one of your first one
of your
favorite character is you don't remember
Ellie Satler or Ian Grant or Ian Malcolm
or Dr Grant or John H or Dodson or uh
[__] sorry excuse me watched it
recently
I remember the characters and the movie
more than the names of the characters
that's not going to sell me on why it
was wrong but something but what you
just got five minutes so let me talk
we're gonna wrap it up pretty soon so
make it quick we're gonna wrap it up
pretty oh God we're just getting started
I don't know if we're wrapping it up
soon but what here here's here's my
point what made this movie any more
memorable than any other summer
blockbuster out there what what is g to
make you remember this movie as a as a
as a good movie other than just for an
hour and a half you were you were kind
of entertained by this somewhat good
okay plot with some dinosaurs in it okay
now I can talk uh everything I've been
saying seeing the park in full force the
the petting zoo watching the kids ride
the little triceratops that finale with
the with the ending Jake Johnson super
funny I thought the SeaWorld stage even
though I saw in the trailer that was
awesome and then when the stage went
under like let's watch them swim like I
want to go there that looked awesome uh
the the seagull part I talked about that
was probably my favorite part in the
whole movie and I still remember that
that and I like the dumb girl hasn't P
attention to them gets eaten um I'm
looking through to uh just cuz I know
more time um I've said it before I like
the plot with the with the jeans placing
I thought cool they're going to mix the
two dinosaurs we like did they take some
conveniences to he has camouflage sure
did that ruin and failure the movie no I
actually thought that the Dom stries was
kind of scary in a couple moments that
opening shot with the egg and the little
babies poking out it actually scared me
I'm like o this is kind of creepy they
looked creepy the fact that he was in
that world and whether we talk about
Owens which you haven't even really
fully pushed me on whether Pratt's
character had the arcot it doesn't
matter he was a fun hero that's what he
did I was fine with it the problem but
he sort of explained you've locked this
animal and he all gets food and he's
been here for 30 years he you messed up
and made a sociopath that's what it was
and I was scared like in a few moments
like I didn't know who he was going to
eat when he escapes and he's getting
smart and he ate the fat guy at the end
and the blood like I was into it I
didn't think and I don't think they like
showed him off in like a annoying bad
ways like the first two sequels did he
was hidden behind the trees and then he
slly like there was a little bit of a
tense buildup I mean I can keep going on
what's fun but I right so listen I'm not
ever going to be able to convince you
that you didn't have fun I can't
obviously obviously you had fun and I'm
sure for the community at large Rotten
Tomatoes positive by the way can I read
some of the quotes from the positive
reviews on Rotten Tomatoes please can I
read one take a deep breath and lower
your expectations at times Jurassic
world is simple dumb and predictable
got one more quote got five minutes can
I get
some not much happens in the first hour
there isn't anything original here those
are the positive reviews for this movie
dan you can go back after his one can I
read so this quote tell me if you agree
with this quote Dan do the dinosaurs
work they do does anything else not
really the battles suffer the rest of
the film does because there's not
they're not connected to anything that
is an emotional equivalent of baby food
Jurassic plays like it was directed by
one of the computers that makes such
prominent use of do you agree because
that was a 1993 review of Jurassic parks
by Kenneth uh Kenneth uh what's his name
Teran from the Los
Angeles who didn't like it so it's
proving there's always a stick in the
mud and it's you guess what Kenneth's
review of Jurassic world was guess what
Jurassic world is Jurassic world is an
enjoyable walk in the park so even that
stick in the mud who gave the perfect
Jurassic Park a negative review love
Jurassic world case closed well that
proves that kenth San is just wrong all
the time as a film critic Teran right or
wrong that's the only top critic on
Rotten Tomatoes that gave Jurassic Park
a negative review I did my res there's
always a stick in the mud yeah I
realized that but here's here's why I'm
arguing that this is a failure yes this
will be your guys I'm sorry we're going
too long this is your closing statement
here's why I'm arguing that Jurassic
world is a failure we sit here every
summer and we talk about these stupid
summer Blockbusters how they're phoned
in how they're poorly written how they
don't have character arcs they don't
have character development it's the same
movie Just cranked out of a machine and
then when one comes comes along like
this that's part of a franchise that we
love cuz I know that you love Jurassic
Park and you don't want to crap on this
movie because you love the franchise we
say we C sequel it's okay because
there's dinosaurs in it I mean you
basically said yeah the plot's dumb yeah
the characters are onedimensional yeah
blah blah blah blah blah no that's not
the bar as filmmakers I'm sorry as movie
goers we should be going to filmmakers
and saying no that's not good enough to
make a summer blockbuster that passible
that the bar is I didn't hate it that's
not good enough because the more of
these that we excuse the more of these
that we let go through the cracks we're
just going to keep getting these same
generic crappy underwritten movies we
need to demand better and when a
filmmaker makes a movie like this in
which they put no effort to be original
in which they put no effort to give
characters with any sort of Dimension
and the only thing that they offer is
Mindless cgx and yes they have failed
they have failed the the fans they have
failed the people that made the original
film and they failed themselves as
filmmakers because they're not pushing
themselves to be better and if people
don't stand up and say something about
it I'm mad as hell and I'm not going to
take it anymore then we're just going to
keep getting these same movies so yes
that's why I call Jurassic world a
failure okay Amen to that but Andy your
response I I don't disagree with
anything you said but I don't love the
franchise the sequels are horseshit like
they're terrible movies they were
terrible ret well but because it was fun
but the point of the matter is they took
what I think is The Impossible which I
actually think they tried would you keep
saying they didn't try and do it
Jurassic Park I think we can all agree
is a perfect movie it's a perfect movie
that holds up that we loved as kids that
we watch again and it's still the first
Jurassic Park movie any kid should watch
but this movie was the perfect sequel to
it it was the bigger louder sillier
thing but the pro but my disagreement
and and the whole fight with you and I
think the masses are agreeing in why
it's you can't call a failure you can't
call this a failure based on the success
it's having based on the reactions it's
getting like Transformers are is a
failure that to me is a complete failure
that is exactly what you're talking
about to say this movie is as bad as
Transformers I never said that that's a
false argument that's man if you are
trying to to say that it's even close
because you everything you said I would
agree with you if we were talking
Transformers to say as to have as much
vital and like passion and hatred on
this movie versus it sequels or
Transformers or so many Blockbuster
terrible movies that are being made I
just don't get it like this movie was
fun it was super fun and I'm going to
I'm not going to say it was okay I loved
it I felt like it's very rare I can turn
off my honest brain like sit and watch a
movie and eat the popcorn and be like
man I'm into this movie and I was
totally in this movie I was it's like is
it is she a little stiff are there
problems I didn't care because the
dinosaurs were back in full force they
was I feel like the first time they
really made the dinosaurs fun they made
the action fun the plot took chances and
made it sort of sillier and crazier and
I was totally on board with it um and I
think uh I think that's pretty much it
all right time okay woo how you feel
about that that here I've eaten three
things of fruit snacks if I lose I feel
like I threw it out all I I I feel like
I've said my piece everyone is good
fight good fight guys um oh man uh I'm
not going to say this is tough but it
this is difficult this is bar burner um
and I think that you guys wow that got
philosophical it was a real question of
the bar and Dan you talked a lot about
that about the bar and what what
standard are we holding these movies to
and I uh you know you made um so many
awesome points uh even though you used a
clip which I think is a little bit
cheating to use gold bloom in your
argument but man um uh you know that
this was uh underdeveloped that this um
you know that this movie doesn't hold up
uh it doesn't hold a candle to what we
should be asking of our movie movies the
question is stacked against you I feel
fun or failure and if you're holding it
to the bar of is it fun Andy had a lot
of specific examples and just kind of
undeniable evidence that it's fun and I
hate to say that's we should hold our
movies to a higher standard than are
they fun or not we should be asking for
another Jurassic Park but what we got
was a fun dinosaur movie and that's why
I got to give Annie the point at the end
of the day even though I I theoretically
agree with everything you said we agree
on the question did you last night when
I was prepping I was like we should have
said good or bad it was good or bad I
think you would have taken it but fun or
failure failure is such a harsh word
that wasn't a complete failure of a
movie that was a fun not as good as
Jurassic Park film I'm glad we got that
out of the way let's reveal
what and I think we should stick to that
bar when we can yeah we should we should
ask if I get a point let's get rid of
this though let's see I was eating those
so Point Andy does he get two o who did
Mike
pick one Andy oh my
god oh Dan fighting out of a hole
wow okay nobody Thanks for believing in
me brother you believe you went against
the champ I went against the champ I
took a risk I wanted you guys to talk a
little bit more about the margarit Ville
tyan yeah the Jimmy Buffett Cameo Chris
Chris Pratt doing his black widow son's
getting real low big guy I wanted to
hear more about the uh how bad the
characters were or lack thereof and I
wanted to hear about well I had to
derail his fun argument yeah okay so
there there's a little bit of clean up
in that round yes um Derek Connelly is
Colin Trevor's partner in comparison to
the other Jurassic Park sequels world is
at 71% lost world is 52 Jurassic Park 3
is 50 and just to let you know IMDb
talking about the product placement is
all Jurassic worlded out where the imbb
logo is now a Jurassic world logo it's
insane no
exp except for all the things that could
have kept all that from happening um
okay so round two I'm going to lose all
the rest of because I put all my eggs in
that basket yeah you can totally your
job is done all the people yelling at me
for yelling sorry that was way too
important to so we all have some strong
opinions about Jurassic world clearly we
do but fight number two let's see if we
can do any better let's pitch the next
Jurassic Park movie I want to hear the
basic plot and I want to hear the title
Dan let's start with you oh go have to
go first n that's number two Mike let's
start be me this is where this is my
time to shine baby need to recharge all
right here we go I'm going to start with
the title which I think if they don't
use this title they're crazy Jurassic
World
War okay I'll admit I don't even know
you're pitch but that's a good title
it's a great title you have my attention
there's a bunch of military references
all right here we go here's the movie
I'm going to pitch you the movie now
tensions with Russia at are an all time
alltime high okay cuz this is the future
it's just really getting tense okay now
it's a future so Russia is being run by
Vladimir Putin's son who I will call
Little Vlad from now on okay I'll call
him little Vlad it's a nice okay it's a
nice day of Naval Base named Pearl
Harbor when
suddenly there's an attack from Russia
not by planes by
pterodactyls that are dropping hydrogen
how they know they're Russian we don't
know yet but have uh the new logo of the
Soviet Union on their little arm there's
an arm band of some kind that's all I'm
saying so they drop hydrogen bombs onto
Pearl Harbor okay Dino Pearl Harbor now
here's the thing we got caught off guard
the Allies got caught off guard we do
not have a dinosaur Army yet they're
going to have to go to the guy who knows
how to train Dinosaurs the best and that
obviously is Owen Chris Pratt's
character from Jurassic world now most
of this movie is sort of like Full Metal
Jacket with Dinosaurs being trained so
the dinosaurs are the the army men
they're the ones that have to get into
shape so he's training a variety of
dinosaurs to be military
experts okay so there's a lot of that
and obviously we're going to like talk
about the horrors of war and like how
tough it is for a dinosaur to get into
shape to to be able to fight Soviet
Union the new Soviet Union okay and
obviously that the the older kid is now
mil the hornier kid uh from d world is
now of military age so he obviously
enlists maybe it's in the future I don't
maybe the other kid is also old enough
the less horny kid is who's it going to
stare at whoa uh there'll be a sexy lady
dinosaur that he can't take his eyes off
of what dinosaur uh wa he's horny for a
dinosaur I don't know that's uh we're
getting off the topic here uh okay here
I just want to I wrote a scene from the
climax of the movie real quick so uh
Spencer I I guess I'll allow it just cuz
I'm very curious
as you're reading the last character I
don't want to say what it is yet okay
Andy you're reading little Vlad Dan
you're reading Owen I'll read stage
Direction all right little vlad's bunker
day little Vlad has Owen on the ropes he
kicks him in the head this is the climax
of the movie you have lost Beauty
American our Soviet dinosaur Army is far
more powerful than American dinosaur
Army Owen spits blood on little vlad's
boots it's red and there's a bunch of it
and now it it's time to kill you and
make your dinosaur surrender oh yeah
well you may want to think a second
before for doing that oh yeah why is
that we see a red sniper Target appear
on L vlad's chest I got backup through
the broken Skylight glass we see a
raptor holding a sniper rifle Raptors
can be snipers now the Raptor gives Owen
a military salute then fires 10 bullets
in a l vlad's chest no not my cold
Soviet heart L Vlad slumps over dead the
sniper Raptor jumps down from the
ceiling good job old friend
and thanks and thank you for teaching me
to speak
English the was talk the the line was
talk English he change wow so that's
that happened all right uh let's see Dan
you're up next hard act to hard act to
follow yes okay so my Jurassic world
sequel picks up after the end of uh what
we have seen in Jurassic world in Jin
due to the unmitigated disaster on
Jurassic world is on the verge of
bankruptcy their only option still on
the verge still on the well now now
they're really on the verge their only
option is to liquidate everything they
have including Jurassic world and their
dinosaurs enter biosen who is biosen
biosen is the company that Dodson worked
for in Jurassic Park the company that
was trying to get the embryos from
Dennis NRI finally after 20 years of
trying to get their hands on these
animals they buy it out from the
liquidation sale of engine and now they
own Jurassic world and if Jurassic Park
and Jurassic world and all of the movies
have taught us anything it's the
corporate greed knows no bounds and it's
endlessly arrogant so they set to to try
to rebuild Jurassic world doing away
with all the as they put it Disneyland
crap that Jurassic world had updated
security system once again they think
that they can do it because everyone
always thinks that they can pull this
off they're led by Dr Henry woo who was
in Jurassic world who is still committed
to these animals being you walking
amongst humans he he does not want to
commit them back to Extinction it's his
life's work so we have a crew hard at
work on wrangling the dinosaurs on
improving on getting Jurassic world back
up to snuff but things keep going wrong
they're being sabotaged they're being
sabotaged by a group of people who snuck
onto Island nublar led by Chris Pratt's
character Owen who seen firsthand what
happens when you mix humans and
dinosaurs he still loves these animals
but he realizes that they're not meant
to coexist so he's there to sabotage the
efforts to rebuild Jurassic world of
course because it's a Jurassic Park
movie things go go wrong dinosaurs run
around they eat people and at the end
sadly Chris Pratt Owen decides that
humans and dinosaurs this is called a
character Arc he decides that humans and
dinosaurs were not meant to coexist it's
just it's not what nature intended so
the movie ends with hey we don't know
that true the movie ends with actually
one of the most striking images from the
original book Jurassic Park the
survivors lifting off from the island
you look down you see dinosaurs running
around and in the island is being carpet
bombed by the Costa Rican military this
is Jurassic world
Extinction well Andy I might have to
crib that title but give it a better
plot oh whoops so in mind it's picture
this opening scene a veroa saltlike kid
has demanded her own dinosaur from her
rich parents and she has it and the she
so she has her little mini Raptor it
doesn't matter which dinosaur it is but
it has some sort of mini Raptor they're
like fine thank you Daddy thank you
Daddy the Raptor just starts eating the
parents oh it's GNA happen door bus open
who's there Dino Busters Chris Pratt and
his team are there now why are you
asking is this happening they're not
actually called Dino Busters but uh
years have passed and unlike your plot
which I feel like I don't want to see it
oh the another the they're done the
engine's bankrupt it's over but the
anime in my movie the uh the animal wrs
people they do not want the animals to
be dead so they need to contain them in
a special place so they can live their
lives peace Y and die whatever so they
are the ones who keeping these
monstrosities alive and Chris Pratt it's
only allowed to kill when necessary um
but Chris Pratt and his team are out to
find the dinosaurs that have escaped and
to find them and to figure out so that
way we get these awesome moments of
dinosaurs throughout the country
throughout the world where the dinosaurs
have sort of created their own new
little caves and homes or infiltrated a
house or a building or an island or a
SeaWorld Planet it's this team's effort
to sort of be the um uh SEAL Team Six to
sort of take out dinosaurs that have
gone Rogue around the planet now that's
that's the plot but of course something
does need to go wrong and so B Wong and
his people have can't it's illegal they
can't do it it's they can't just do
another Island they can't do it so it's
completely Black Market it's completely
sketchi done um they've been still doing
their research um they are building
something that they didn't even realize
they could build so sorry I'm building a
Trilogy this is now part two I'm going
I'm rush to the end before part two ends
they they go and the thing I feel like
we've never seen these movies I want to
figure out the dino the dino Hunters
they'll be a better name but the dino
Hunters are out and they realize we then
see near the end Hawaii is starting
getting attacked and we realize that the
dinosaurs have evolved and there are
eggs and a whole Nest underwater and we
realize oh crap there's a whole bunch of
a new species underwater and underwater
dinos that have escaped and have been
around so that's the end of part two but
then to even make it more of a how are
we going to take this out we realize BD
Wong we reveal it and he realized
something that D he captured might
illuminate a legacy that no one's ever
really been able to figure out which is
a dragon and they have crafted a dragon
at the end of the part two so part two
is called Evolution Jurassic world
Evolution and part three is Jurassic
world Extinction where we bring in a
dinosaur which I've done the homework it
can exist with the ni placing so Dragon
experts have said and that just
Drane degree George R Martin are you
talking about George R Martin all right
guys I mean I'll give you each like a
sentence or two to uh everything
everyone went way too long so I I well I
was going to say his is yours is just
the same old thing we've seen you're
doing the retread again it's an updated
Park we want to see the park go again I
don't I'm so over that and yours as
silly as it sounds uh I just it's
impossible how long would it take to
train every dinosaur good point Sandy go
ahead here's what I'm saying this movie
we have to make a sequel to Jurassic
world it's Jurassic world the thing we
like about it is it's crazy nonsense we
want more crazy nonsense yours takes the
end of the second movie to get to a
dragon if a dragon was in the First Act
I may have to give it to you but we're
getting waiting to the second movie my
movie starts with Soviet pterodactyls
bombing Pearl Harbor we want nonsense
you're trying to do a thoughtful movie
and I'm sorry that's not what Jurassic
world was and we can't make a sequel
It's not going to make any sense people
going what is this thoughtful movie
that's crap they want nonsense and I'm
delivering baby you are delivering
nonsense Dan people don't want nonsense
Jurassic Park was a thoughtful movie
you're right Jurassic world was not a
thoughtful movie I'm trying to make a
good movie I'm not quite sure so are
they are they in like the real world
how' they get off the island I I just
don't a dragon is that I don't I think
that's a little even for Jurassic world
and it's nonsense I think a dragon might
be a little too far to to go and
dropping bombs on Pearl Harbor is is
even farther so I think you guys are
pushing it so far into the realm of
nonsense that it just becomes even worse
than it is I want to actually bring it
back to its roots and make a good fun
action-packed yet thoughtful movie that
people will I'm embracing my dragon I
think he's looking up but just to be
clear I so my dragon comes in earlier
then so what we rewrites Dragon expert
Dragon expert but the dragon say if the
pterodoras whatever the pterodactyl DNA
is mixed with an alligator mixed with um
for the wingspan and then alligator for
the skin and then there are toads that
can spew Venom the prac you win for you
win for best dragon um all right I think
that I have everything I need here uh
Mike yours I love like if you could have
just made a little more grounded of the
dinosaur Army I think we all want to see
a dinosaur Army movie but without it
being a offensive to the living
survivors of Pearl Harbor and just
having all this other craziness going on
that Andy yours I would love Dino
Busters as a TV show of them just
rounding up all these dinosaurs Dan you
get this one you respected the lore you
respect to the theme of the franchise
and you brought some finality to it with
if they bomb Jurassic Park surely they
can't make another one of these so Dan
gets the point good job interesting
point that's a fair that's a fair it'll
make it'll make no money what do any of
us really want to see a sequel I feel
like Jurassic world I don't at all
actually I had a picture that got
rejected where the first scene was Chris
Pratt waking up from that was a weird
dream and then I just pitched Jurassic
world how I would have made it all right
good job guys let's go to round
three now Nick Chow Nick 77 Chow on
Twitter asked us a really fun question
that ties into Jurassic world also um
Jurassic world is the fourth Jurassic
Park movie so what is the best fourth
film in a movie for franchise uh you can
pick Jurassic world if you want let's
start with Dan well my choice won't be
Jurassic world but it will be a movie
that was released this summer I I
generally try not to be reactionary to
things but I looked at all the options
and I believe that Mad Max Fury Road is
the best fourth feature in any franchise
first of all it's the best out of any of
the Mad Max films which is rare for a
fourth feature and it's also just an
incredible action movie I mean you don't
even have to qualify as like it's
incredible for the for the franchise or
it's incredible for the genre it's just
a great movie whether it was the first
or the 10th or the 15th movie of the
franchise so um I I'll probably defend
it against their arguments but my pick
is Mad Max Fury Road all right Andy uh
my Max is Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire I feel like um there's a lot of
good movies in there especially akabar I
probably said that wrong asab
asabar a trap not my movie back bar but
go of fire to me was the first like was
really the Harry Potter movie where it's
like you had them uh teenagers like
first falling in love and their hormones
are acting up I feel like Ron and and uh
um Harry had like they got really pissed
at each other like it just felt like the
finally the Harry Potter kids growing up
in a more dramatic sense um and
furthermore I just it sort of was the
better Hunger Games sort of in a way
where it had this the tri- Wizard
championship I think was actually pretty
scary for kids and really took the
franchise to sort of Darker level and
the I can keep going but the the the
most important part to me is is the
finale like the the moment with
Voldemort where he's finally gets to
Showdown Voldemort which now we've
waited four movies and he's finally
there in the ghost form and then his
parents are there to help him fight Vore
like it's super touching and I think a
better finale in some ways than the than
the final finale just because it was a
little bit more emotional or I feel like
Harry was almost too stoic in that final
moment where they're just WS are staring
at each other and who's like who's laser
is going to get to them first um so I
just think Goblin of fire was a perfect
movie plus it killed off pson great Mike
uh I'm going to go with Mission
Impossible 4 uh this much like what Dan
pointed about Mad Max this is by far the
best of the mission Possible movies
which is crazy when you're talking about
a fourth movie because generally fourth
movie is like they put Jaws in 3D or
something like that's usually what
happens when you're getting that late in
the late in the franchise but this is
just one of the best action movies
period like all the set pieces are great
all the action is Fun the character
stuff is good there's some really like
nice little like kind of twists and nods
to the old movie that happened at the
end of it Tom Cruz is climbing on the
tallest thing in the world that's one of
the Hallmark you think what else can he
do obviously he goes to the top of the
building in Dubai it's amazing I saw it
in IMX it's incredible uh this thing I
don't know I just I love watching this
movie I watch I've seen it like five
times it's incredible okay some uh yeah
fight it out um well to speak to Mission
Impossible I actually disagree I think
the third one is is the best movie I I
remember enjoying Ghost Protocol as I
was watching it but the only thing I
actually do remember from the movie is
Tom Cruz uh scaling the large building I
remember a lot more about three the
great villain from Philip Seymour
Hoffman and the the chips the chips in
the head that'll that'll make you
that'll explode after a certain amount
of time and I thought it was a more
personal story for Ethan Hunt so I
actually prefer three over four and uh
Harry Potter um I think Goblet of Fire
is uh in the top Echelon of Harry Potter
movies but I think that there were some
there were a couple that were better I
think Order of the Phoenix and Half Half
Blood Prince and uh the last movie
deathly Halls 2 were better better so I
don't think it's bad but I think that
Fury Road of the four is the best movie
overall just you know taking taking the
other movies out of it I think it's a
superior movie to the other two not
saying that they're bad uh the thing
with Fury look first of all say Goblet
of Fire like Goblin of fire is pretty
good but a goblet of fire is like
moments there are moments in it that are
great but I'm not sure that the movie is
great there's a whole Triwizard
Tournament and like anytime sports are
on I zone out and that's sort of like I
don't remember exactly what happens in
but I remember the Voldemort thing I
remember that one kid dying and like
that's those are the two moments but
other than that Crush uh uh I can't
remember her name j Chang Chang yes
right okay now that you've refreshed my
memory that that comes back uh and now
Mad Max like Mad Max obviously great we
love this movie but it's been like 20
years since the Lad last Mad Max it's
like Mission Impossible has had to
maintain a franchise over four movies
with like sort of the same ingredients I
understand that some of the the
directors obviously have all changed but
like it's like if I were to give you ice
cream once a week by that fourth week
you'll be excited for the ice cream but
it's like it's this sort of the same ice
cream the idea that like somehow you
made the ice cream better the fourth
week is pretty amazing now if I didn't
give you ice cream for 20 years and then
I came back and it was all new ice cream
and there were better cameras there were
different stars there was technology now
that could blow something out you'd be
like wow where did this come from this
is amazing and we all we really like cuz
the movie just came out we're sort of
just still in the globe of it and we
really haven't like we know it's great
we just haven't we don't have a proper
time to really digest it and assess if
this is really this great of a movie
there's plenty of character stuff in
that movie that I would have begged to
see and most of it's sort of just action
I think the jury's out on how amazing it
is we know it's great we just don't know
how amazing yeah I got it chadman I I
have the same that's totally great
argument you had and I feel like but I
also feel like I I to to be perfecton I
haven't gotten see madmax yet so it's
hard for me I know my nerd cuts out but
just from the trailers alone I know your
movie is a better action movie than
Mission Impossible 4 like it just
Mission Impossible 4 is exactly what Dan
said I was like I don't remember which
one I mean I remember him climbing the
building I remember the sandstorm and
Simon Peg and maybe the hallway scene
was funny it's talk about moments like
that movie is key is just moments like I
can't figure out the rest of why that
movie was good versus madmax I think
yeah I mean Goblet of Fire it's like
after say how
doab after askaban it like you how do
you compete with that that was a great
movie uh kran made an awesome version of
that movie um and I think alaire took it
in in a fantastic way to keep that
franchise strong and moving to where it
did it's a it's a better movie as a
fourth film in a franchise using
semantics than Mad Max which is like I
don't I don't really count that as the
fourth film in the franchise like so
many people haven't even seen the first
three like it's a reboot it's it's great
it's a it's movie but it's also sort of
unfair because it hasn't stood the test
of time we haven't been able to really
sit on it and make sure it works whereas
I do challeng I think to all of Goblet
of Fire is stronger like uh in as of the
films and the cannon of which ones are
best it really does put them at odds
each other for the like a in a really
strong way and it brings it it's like
the best high school movie out of all
those movies because they're in school
the whole time but then it also gets
really dark and serious and that finale
is something they weren't I don't think
be able to really get as strong in the
later films okay great guys uh I'm
calling it I can't respond quick
response uh I disagree with you I think
that they hit more emotional Beats at
the end of later Harry Potter movies and
to say I think it's more impressive to
come back with a movie 20 years later
Mission imp possible actually reinvents
itself I think every movie The only
component that does stay the same other
than Ving Rings popping up to say hi is
Tom crw so I think that mission possible
actually does reinvent itself every time
so I think that it's more impressive to
bring something back after 20 years that
the audience has no connection to and
make a movie so great that people are
now back into the FR your decks were
loaded again I mean it's like it's not
that hard because the first movies
aren't really as it's fresh it doesn't
look like the old movies it doesn't like
anything like them it's a completely
different movie so so I get it you could
say that's the best cuz it's the great
action but is it really the best fourth
film in a franchise that's where I would
well semantic arguments aside semantic
arguments we allowed we allowed Mad Max
uh Fury Road to be considered um he said
he doesn't really care about continuity
but it's still there is some continuity
between the first three so it's
technically the fourth Mad Max movie you
guys all made some awesome arguments um
I like Mike you're you're you're so
right that it's a much higher degree of
difficulty to stick mission impossible
for when you get one every year or two
uh but again I don't think we can hold
that against Mad Max but Andy you said
that uh uh Goblet of Fire is the first
one that or is was a darker one it had a
new tone um as caban kind of did that
that was the first one where you knew
that the kids had grown up and it was
the first real good dark Harry Potter
movie um I got I I hate to play
semantics but Mad Max Fury Road as uh as
Dan explained is the best movie on its
own and it's uh it gets the point it's
impeccable
I don't know how we were supposed to
beat that Ma I agree I hav even seen it
and I probably agree and yes we have
some fact checks but I would just like
to deduct a point from everyone for not
picking Rocky 4 so I almost picked Rocky
I'd like to I'm not going to but real
real quick on the previous round Dr
Peter Hogarth of the University of
York's biology Department says that
Dragon creation is possible but it would
be very complicated uh writer director
George Miller calls the madmax Fury Road
a revisiting and he says that is a
sequel to the other Mad Max films and he
says to think about it like James Bond
they just recast like James Bond and
also I want to point out that talking
about the mission Impossibles and not
being able to remember the different
sequels our current host Spencer Gilbert
lost an episode of movie fights because
he could not remember the difference
between Mission Apostle 3 thanks for
bringing that up I'll be sure to kick it
to you next time what an what an idiot
don't don't say that to the guy in
charge of your
screen let's keep the camera here uh all
right round four you guys moving on all
right
uh some big news broke this week uh
Walking Dead Shane John Bernthal has
been cast as The Punisher everyone
rubbed their heads on Netflix's
Daredevil season 2 uh there's some other
big daredevil characters so at sorry at
this is the crazy one asked who should
play Electra and bullseye on Daredevil
and to clarify not to chime in it but
the this is a TV fight which we don't
normally do but because they're going to
be in the MCU in theory that was our
fudge of how we allowed this question in
yeah you could have all them uh ious
fudge dropping by Infinity War for a for
a shot so we're going to start with Andy
who should play Electra and Bullseye
this was tough uh there were said it
even as contest wow but this was
probably the toughest one to go through
because I I had to really sort of think
about and go through um Electra is a
badass and she's hot and she but I want
more than just that like I want
something uh like I just want a real
person so the person I already picked
was Lizzy Kaplan for Masters of Sex and
the interview um she just feels like a
real woman she's really funny the one
thing she hasn't proven to anybody is
can she kick ass but I feel like anybody
can learn to kick ass with stunt people
and the proper choreography like I want
a person who's going to be to like d
more dramatic badass to like really go
toe-to-toe with them and I feel like
she's fantastic in Master of Sex I loved
her spin in the interview I think she's
got an edge and sarcasm to her sarcasm
to her um I think she I can keep going
but she's good for my Bullseye I'm
picking um Aaron Paul from Breaking Bad
I love him I think he was great I miss
seeing Jesse I think this is a different
type of role but I think we saw parts of
when he would go crazy or ludicrous like
that's what I want my Bullseye is just a
sociopath who's going to lose it and I
would love to give uh Aaron Paul who I
think was a fantastic actor in that
movie sort of a fun role to chew on and
really kill it as a villain all right
Mike um I'm this is uh dreamcasting
because I don't know if we necessarily
can get these people I don't know why I
had to say that I just did though Emily
Blunt for Electra Emily Blunt we would
buy her as a a ninja we've seen her
kickass we buy her as Murdoch's
beautiful love interest obviously The
One That Got Away now Emily Blunt's got
everything she also like can play sort
of like cool and dead inside which is
what you sort of Need for Electro which
is a character who is a ninja who has
killed a lot of people who is probably
trying to like numb her brain to not
relive all those horrible memories I
think she's perfect uh as far as
Bullseye I'm going to go with Timothy
olant from Justified because I like
there's there's some different ways that
people play or write excuse me write
Bullseye in the comics and I like
Bullseye when he's a little bit more
measured sometimes you're writing
Bullseye and he's sort of a crazy like
Joker kind of a guy I don't think that's
is fun to play off a murx so I want
somebody who's like steady and and
Timothy olant is like that I want like a
steady scary guy who just kind of has
that gaze and you go oh this guy could
really do some damage that's why I
picked Timothy Alan all right awesome
Dan so for Electra I wanted to go with
somebody because Electra in the comics
is Greek so I wanted to go with somebody
who could kind of bring that kind of
European veralos no that European
Mystique to it so I picked uh Eva Green
who was an um French uh well she's you
know French European I didn't say she
had to be Greek I but I like that I like
that Europe she brings that kind of
European Mystique to everything that she
does which I think has been missing from
definitely Jennifer Garner doing it um
and I don't know she's kind of played
you were saying she needs to be cool and
dead inside and she's she's done she's
shown that a couple times in a couple
movies so I think that she would be good
for the
and then for Bullseye I know that we
made a lot of fun of him in one of our
Honest Trailers but I was looking for
somebody young and somebody who just
looks kind of crazy and so I went with
Will polter who's the uh look look at
the he's the he's he's that guy oh
eyebrows his eyebrows from Hunger Games
uh I think that he bull I think you need
kind of a younger guy for Daredevil
because he's he's kind of a little bit
older in the show a kind of a younger
guy for him to play off of plus he has
good mask face I mean I think he could
really he could really rock a mask cover
up those caterpillars looks a little
unhinged I think he could really play
crazy so those are my choices I I just
got to jump on that one did you remember
him in maze rener like he was awful it
was awful awful but he was playing a bad
guy he was punchable yeah I do not want
to see him play Bullseye I don't think
there's anything fun about that the
other my other response to your both of
your females they're so obvious I've
seen them both do that so many times I
want something outside the box I want a
Heath Ledger moment I want something
that's going to surprise us and be like
that's really fun also Electra I want
her to go against rosero Dawson like
there's a fun she's coming back she's a
good love interest for him already like
there's clearly gonna be a love triangle
and I want someone with the acting chops
who can do that I'm not saying they both
both couldn't do that but I think I want
someone a little bit more funnier than
both your choices like so Andy did it
already I want you guys to tell me how
you see them fitting into the existing
cast interacting with Rosario Dawson and
uh and Daredevil well uh well Timothy
olant was is Bullseye I think that
you're going to get like you're G to
sort of have almost
parallels of each other with with
Bullseye versus Daredevil like like you
have instead of like having like crazy
guy and then the guy who's like real
straight and serious you're going to
sort of have those two guys in a very
similar manner sort of like facing off
with their like serious tone and then
and their intensity and I think that's
going to be a nice thing when you're
you're getting those two things as
opposed to the thing we usually see
which is when the villain's crazy and
then the bad and then the good guy is
really like steady uh as far as uh Emily
Blunt like like I can imagine like first
of all Electra is not like the most
hilarious character so I don't know
we're talking about Lizzy Kaplan oh it's
not what I mean but yes but like so I so
you want somebody who's like somebody
who has worked with the ninja group The
Hand like you want somebody steady like
that and you want her to bring in the
fact that like you're terrified her you
want everybody to really be freaked out
by her because she's such a Deadly
Assassin and you're going to bring that
but she also obviously is a beautiful
person and somebody who has a lot of
Charisma and you're you're going to also
just see what Matt Murdoch sees in her
and also be in love with her Charisma is
what I'm speaking about I see sarcasm
and fun like what do you wrap it back
and forth she's not a comedian got it
Dan yeah I mean I think I see Electra
fitting in as you know I agree it could
lead to some romantic complications with
roserio Dawson they they they dropped a
little bit of a hint of Electra in the
first season they talked about Matt
having dated a Greek girl uh and I think
that she comes in as a figure from
Matt's past who does kind of complicate
things for him because at the end of
season one he's become the Daredevil
hero the you know the big guy and I
think that rather than him just doing
that it would be fun to add a new
wrinkle to add someone from his past to
upset the order because I think on
television that's what keeps it
interesting is when you upset the
established order as far as um Timothy
olant and Aaron Paul I think to a degree
um I I think that to balance it out I
don't think Bullseye should be Timothy
Alan's done Hitman first of all which is
kind of a weird same character thing I I
don't I don't think that Bullseye should
be a really dark character I think he
should be more of a a fun character
somebody who who takes joy in what he
does and is really unhinged I don't
think will polter's problem with the
Maze Runner I think it was the material
not so much him I know that he was
supposedly impressed some people when he
was auditioning for the It remake that
may or may not happen I think that he's
got the chops I think the material
failed him and the Maze Runner he's
played a weirdo he was also in Meet the
Millers or whatever he's just a weirdo
kid and I just want to punch him in the
face like I can't take that seriously
choice for but no but I think the
problem I love allant but I don't want
that serious person in that Daredevil I
a little bit of sociopath a little bit
of crazy and I feel like Aaron Paul
could bring that with like his sort of
manness and just and keep it tramatic
and not in a silly way but make it a
little bit more exciting which I don't
want to see Hitman walk in and do it and
then I still um uh to the girls I just
don't I don't see why why are we just
put oh yeah she was good in 300 and he
was
good but I just feel like I just feel
like they're gonna play the same thing
like I just don't to me I'd love to give
someone who hasn't done that the chance
to do it and I think Electra needs to be
all the things you said and I think you
want the best dramatic actress and Emily
Blunt's great I like her I'm not trying
to knock either of them Eva Green
probably is a better dramatic actor but
she comes with so much baggage of like
I've seen her as the sociopath a million
times in a million movies well she's not
playing a
sociopath I just it's going to be hard
to not see that to me I just think
that's it just well it'll be hard for me
not to see Jesse with Aaron Paul I mean
fair or not it's gonna be hard for me
for him to play another kind of
screaming character and not immediately
think of Breaking Bad personally that
would be my knock on on that on that
choice I think he should go do
comedy he should go break out the other
way personally okay Mike you had your
hand half raised then I'm GNA call it I
I don't want to see Teen Bullseye like
even though Aaron Paul's probably a 35y
old man like he's like teen he's still
like kind of a teenager to me uh and and
as far as like casting like Lizzy Kaplan
maybe but like I need to see a tape I
want to go with something real that I
know can work before I go with something
that I think might work because I like
her sort of okay interesting so I'm
going to call it uh good picks all
around this one is tough because there's
two choices for each one and I think
that Andy you made a great case for
Aaron Paul But Lizzy Kaplan is your
poison pill I just wasn't convinced on
why she could fit in this series Dan uh
Eva Green another great call Will polter
I mean no for all the above reasons
listed he's not a great actor he's too
young uh Mike you picked the safe answer
but it's going to it's going to carry
you through this round I would see both
of those fitting into that series uh
Mike gets the point
all righty conservative sometimes wins
sometimes conservative wins uh the
Ronald Reagan a movie yeah so sorry
we're going to probably rush through
these because we've already hit an hour
and we are going we really so we got one
fight left till the speed round so let's
keep this quick two fights left two
fight two fights left oh my God oh my
God okay so moving extra quick uh round
five hnav at hnav pather asked what is
the best fake movie within a movie uh
interesting question so this is not a
real movie that exists but movies
reference other movies all the time
what's the best one that we've seen
let's start with Mike all right I'm
going to win this immediately Terren and
philli asses of fire from the South Park
movie are you kidding me within the
first few minutes Terrence and Philip
are dancing in the street having like a
fart off singing a song called Uncle I
don't I'm not allowed to say it Uncle
last week Uncle lover say it can I say
it yeah uncle [__] my goodness what a
song this is like musical it's fun it's
hilarious like it's this this is
obviously the best fake movie in a movie
of all time okay strong words Dan I'll
fight back later but mine is simple Jack
from Tropic Thunder there are a lot of
fake movies in movies but the the like a
like a finely crafted Diamond you don't
find the perfect bad movie that often in
Hollywood and simple Jack I would watch
that movie 50 times that looks like the
most ridiculous movie ever made I've
never wanted to see a full movie more
than Ben Stiller's character trying to
go good in the worst movie ever made I
would love to see that movie okay Andy
my pick is James Cameron's Aquaman in
entourage now this counts because we we
talked about it but I'm like because
it's in the cannon of the movie which
the entage movie had so therefore we're
allowing this um so James Cameron's
Aquaman like I I just think everyone who
saw it was like yeah I kind of want to
watch that I want to watch that movie I
think if we had I wish we could have had
Cameron go underwater he's so great at
and make an amazing underwater
Blockbuster um than Avatar like I would
have loved to have seen him to do that
and I think he would have helped
reinvent the DC franchise before and I
just think that would have been such a
fun Choice going straight into then
these things like your movie is
ridiculous it's a hour and a half movie
of me making fun of a mentally
challenged person like that's awful no
hour either comedy it's either a comedy
or it's just a hour and a half long uh
you know mentally challenge joke which I
just don't can't support it's like you
laugh at it uncomfortably but but I I
even think in the movie it's slightly
questionable like should we be making
this many jokes uh with the RW which
spawn the rule you never go full but so
uh but anyway so that's my struggle with
that one it's like are you taking it is
it a serious movie or are you watching
it as a
comedy well you're you're making another
yet another straw man argument the joke
is not about mentally challenged people
The Joke is on Ben Stiller that's what
you're laughing at you're not laughing
at people that are mentally challenged
you're laughing at this a-hole actor who
thinks he's good enough to do it without
being horribly offensive it's so stupid
that you're laughing at him and you
don't get those kind of movies I a lot
of theater when they were laughing they
were laughing at that joke I think
personally I think you have to judge
these movies based on the fake
filmmakers intentions and did they
succeed okay because this was a movie
designed to be a serious dramatic work
in the movie and it's laugh it's like
the room of the Tropic Thunder universe
so that means that it did not do what it
was intended the movie is a failure this
movie we've seen one clip of it and man
does it look terrible it made $116
million we're talking about best movie
walking out yours said people walking
out that's fine but do I like Vincent
Chase running down the Santa mon no
barely like deaded in a tuxedo wandering
down the Santa Monica Pier taking his
tie out first of all it's the middle of
the day why is he got his tuxedo on is
he playing the piano at Nordstrom what
is he doing
he weirdest sequence we don't even know
what he it's like a there's a Title Wave
coming on first of all this is 20 6 this
is the height of when this is the dark
serious gritty take obviously James
Cameron has no grasp on this material he
does not know what he's doing he thinks
he just making Batman Begins again and
he didn't even come back for the second
one that's what a big turd this movie
was James C would not make another one
of these movies and Vincent Chase is a
terrible actor Vincent Chase and Mandy
Moore that's who you want to see as
Aquaman I hate to say it I'd rather see
Jason mima's version than Vincent chase
out of all the trailers in that movie
that's the last movie I'd want to see
all three of them would have been so
much more fun point I I'm going back to
the point of you said it your two films
were bombs in this universe whereas mine
wasn't on top of that I'm I'm never a
huge fan of the Canadian episodes and in
fact neither was the audience when the
when they did the W cardsman bomb
happened and they're like let's do an
all C Canada episode that's not the
episode we're talking about the point is
I don't want to watch an hour and a half
of teren and Phil and it's not an hour
and a half it's three hours long if you
watch South Park lior it comes out 3
hours later Terence and Phillip the
whole reason is that they're hacks
that's what they're set up to be is that
comedy is terrible you saw the first
minute and the last minute of that movie
I guarantee you the 3 hours in the
middle of it is the worst piece of crap
you've ever seen Uncle [__] all
laughing we're all laughing at it
seriously that's hilarious seriously to
me to all of us I think we would all
agree where does that movie go from
there that's just the start of it
there's going to be some crazy stuff in
that three hours the laughter will wear
off you will get bored Colts build up
around terrible movies people go out in
midnight and they watch terrible Movies
10 15 20 times in a row and that's what
simple jack is all right
time time guys wow oh man I was so on
board with Uncle [__] until he reminded
me that it's three hours long and you
are so right that we did see one great
uh fart based song but to have three
hours of that you're right it would be
good simple Jack is awful I
mean it's an awful idea it's an awful
movie watch it's embarrassing it's
offensive it's uh yeah you could watch
it as a joke but that we're what we're
asking is what the best fictional movie
and the last one left on the board is
James Cameron's Aquaman this is movie
I've been mad that's crazy shouldn't
even be eligible that's another
legitimately upset it's in a TV show
three hours though that I I I did not
know that and that's a kicker can we
fact check that Terren and Philip would
be three hours long of uh of that but
yeah till then I'm going with James
camon talk on the spere what oh we all
want to see it the only fake movie that
was not in a movie we movie I don't
either good or not show that clip of him
on the pier again please do we have it
no all right whatever
BR why would we want to see that movie
Jes Cameron's Aquaman it is it is a
three-hour film it's a 3our f film
serious Chase was taking that love that
also we're going to the last round with
threeway with the three-way tie are we
so I question I had are you sure cuz
Andy got two points there oh my bad oh
two points on that one one more on the
first one
so anyways well you'll figure out the
score I'm going to go round I got
two Mike has two he has two I guess
excellent oh yes that's right you're
right you did get a point for that my
apologies it's my first time judging
guys all one we'll get it back on back
on the rails cuz round six it's a tease
for this week's honest trailer sort of
because we saw the first promotional art
for Independence Day 2 at the licensing
Expo 2015 now the thing thing about the
licensing Expo sometimes there are
stories about toys there that happen at
a licensing Expo W so perhaps there's a
story about toys in the next honest
trailer which is very exciting hint but
that is not the fight we're having today
the fight is what is the best movie
poster of all time now you all answer
this beforehand and you all pick Jaws so
Jaws is off the table so what is the
best non Jaws movie poster we are going
to start with Dan it's it's but I went
with the poster that I think creates the
most lasting image and the one that I
think gets you most excited about the
movie and that's the Exorcist it's very
simple it's a very striking image it's
the title of the movie and the light
coming down to the Man Standing on the
street you don't know exactly what's up
in that in that room but you know it's
terrifying and you know that it's
probably not good news it's creepy I
think it sets a good tone for the movie
and and it makes you curious about it so
that's why I picked the Exorcist all
right uh Andy I picked uh Who you gonna
call Ghostbusters of course uh to me
that poster is so iconic it's not only
just a perfect movie poster that sums up
what the movie is but it's the logo for
the business it's a what they call it
diagetic it's a a spe it's so important
to the movie It's So integral to movie
it's something that's still around to
this day on laptops and backpacks and
t-shirts and it so perfectly sums up the
tone of the movie what it's about the
comedic Edge um I will go in more but uh
that alone is my choice okay hey M all
right um a movie poster I believe should
before it comes out give like an
intriguing like look at it and also kind
of give you a sense of the movie and
then after become an iconic image that
everyone remembers is why I'm so I'm
picking ET because that does that
perfectly you see the poster it it gives
you a really good sense of the Wonder
and the imagination that you're going to
have in the movie and after the fact
this is one of the most iconic Movie
images if not the most iconic Movie
images of all time yours spoils the
movie
so all that it's like yes isn't an
iconic image from the movie Yes But as a
poster I know he's going to fly in a
bike with ET in the basket so it's like
to me that's what I don't like about it
I love I mean it's hard to beat that
hard to fight with it but it's like it
is what it is it's a spoiler alert when
you're going to see the movie whether
you realize it or not you're going to
realize that moment happens as something
to leave with it and keep in your heart
and watch it later sure but as a movie
poster I don't want it to spoil my movie
um and yours does it a little bit too
but not as as
but whereas mine doesn't spoil anything
that's what I love about it it's so
simple and marketing these days are so
bad at giving you too much and putting
too many heads on the poster and
everything like it just none of these
logos are are one of these logos is
shared the most and it's the poster to
Ghostbuster well yeah but it's it's an
advertisement for the film it's it you
how does it I don't get how it sums up
the tone of the movie it's a cartoon if
I didn't know a Ghostbusters was I'd
look at it and I'd see a cartoon ghost
and itd say Ghostbusters and I'm like
okay it's a it's become iconic
the tone because it's a scary ghost and
you think scary not scary ghost it's a
cartoon character you think ghosts are
scary but they're making themselves like
the exterminators they're the
exterminators of ghosts they're from
they're making the scary the mo I think
you can it's like oh cool what's that
it's it's we're going to stop your
ghosts and that's what the tone of the
movie is it's not a scary movie
Ghostbusters and then it sort of tricks
you and it sort of is it's a fun movie
that's that that that logo completely
sums it up to me we're associating all
that stuff though after the fact right
we don't like looking at that before you
go oh this must be a cartoon about ghost
it's a it's a striking advertisement and
it's great it's iconic we love it but
but I but well no the Bill Murray Dan
akroy uh Sigourney Weaver text above
would help you not realize that so the
text is the selling point on that
post be
the you're saying it's G to be a cartoon
being anle uh Mike I agree with Andy
somewhat in that the ET image is it is
one of the most uh iconic images in
cinema of all time but what only in
context of the movie and I agree that
that if you see that image on the poster
you're going to be waiting for that in
the movie where I think that my choice
has it over is that it's the only one
that you look at and it and it actually
gives you a sense of what you're going
to feel during the movie and it gives
you a sense of what you're going to get
in the movie which is like this is going
to be a really kind of scary like what
what's up there it intrigues you it
makes you interested it makes you
curious it makes you a little scared it
sets the fact that it's this is going to
be this isn't just you know it's not
like the old horror posters with
somebody like oh screaming this is
saying like no this is this is going to
be an intense movie it's going to be a
mysterious movie and and it just kind of
fills you with the sense of dread I
think it's the closest thing to the
actual movie of any of the other posters
that I think it does that because of the
movie I'm not scared by that poster if
anything that looks like a foreign film
if I knew nothing about it the word The
Exorcist scares me more than the light
light is a good thing like light from
the god the sky like if I'm really
breaking down the poster which we're
task with doing like I'm not scared
there I'm scared because I know what
that that movie is but like if I was
walking by and had no context of the
movie I would be like what oh that looks
like some some Far movie I don't want to
watch I don't I don't see creepy the and
The Exorcist was the only one that I
didn't have in my head that's the one I
had to look up so like it's it's a good
it's a great image it like does like set
a tone for it but it's also something I
had to go what was the what I assume
like is it that's I'm sorry about that
that's a it's one of the most famous
I'll give you my final I'll shut up
clearly the most iconic but also I think
it I challenge it does tell you what the
movie is it sets up the tone without
spoiling which your movie does and I
just don't think yours helps sell the
creepiness and scariness that film is um
it's just a pretty image and and you
need to see there's no way to know what
exact I mean you see a bike you see some
but you don't know what that's going to
be it's not a move like oh he gets on
his bike and runs away from the cops
you're not oh yeah that's what that
poster was well then you'll remember oh
yeah that's what the poster is but the
whole movie isn't them on a bike in the
sky that's not the whole that's not just
like people riding bikes in the sky it's
not it's it's a part of the movie you go
oh that's from the poster and it'll be
nice it'll be like that's that's the
Wonder I saw on the poster I what you'll
think I just think that's an image
that's better left to discover in the
course of the movie because it's a very
magical moment of the movie and it I
agree with Andy it does take a little
bit of the magic out of it if you've
seen it on posters plasted all around
town and I just think that year poster
is a logo the same as the Batman poster
was the bat symbol that's it's it's
certainly an effective advertisement but
it's not a great poster it's just a logo
I think that mine is actually an
indication of the kind of film that
you'll be seeing and it's a very
striking image even though Mike isn't
didn't remember it I think it's a very
striking image and one that people do
remember okay wow good stuff guys um
this is
tough uh sorry Dan I think Andy's
argument was fatal that that image just
isn't scary I mean The Exorcist is the
scariest movie of all time and that's a
guy waiting to go into a house um it's
it's a nice photo and a uh also it did
not hang around long enough it didn't
immediately spring to mind like the
other two did when you mentioned him
this is the is the tough battle um
they're both iconic as we've SE said
before uh they're both uh still around
and they both kind of sum up the tone of
the movie and I got to say we're just
talking about the poster I I don't think
it's relatively fair to call it a
spoiler for the film I think by the time
you're in there uh and you're watching
that movie you're so caught up in the
magic you don't think back oh I saw the
poster for this he's going to start
flying just on the poster alone ET is a
beautiful image that's also iconic
whereas uh that Ghostbusters is is a
cool logo but it's not as far as art
goes just looking at the image itself ET
is the better post you made the better
argument for it Mike gets the point the
only way it would have been better is if
et's best friend botanicus was waving to
him from the Green Planet in the
background that's the only way the image
would have been better hash we can Okay
so this sets up wow an interesting back
speed breaker Andy vers Dan uh Jason
before we go on do you have any fact
checks or anything else you want to say
good so I'm impressed I made it this far
you're all doing great we've made it
that's why my record sucks because I
always go against the best The Good the
good stuff yeah well we wouldn't have it
any other way uh before we get to the
speed round we'd like to once again
thank our sponsors at Squarespace if
you'd like to yell at us about what we
said today and comments just aren't
enough use Squarespace is easy to use
tools to build Andy was wrong.com or Dan
was right.org or whatever you want uh
and for a free trial with no credit card
required Click The annotation or visit
squarespace.com backmy fights sign up
using the code movie fights to save 10%
on a new subscription Squarespace build
it beautiful now the speed
round the rules are tibre or tiebreaker
round first
tibre we have one tiebreaker question to
see who will advance to the speed round
just just confirm I'm just going to go
with the first speed round question okay
let's do that between Andy and Dan the
rules are uh the player who goes first
gets 15 seconds to answer second player
gets a 15sec rebuttal and the first guy
gets a 5c rebuttal over that we all
understand how it works and you guys
will pick up on it if that didn't make
sense so first speed round tiebreaker
question you can sorry to be clear
because I know do this if there's a
choice of two or it's broad you can warn
Us in advance okay I will warn you in
advance this is Broad when we this is
very
broad uh okay you ready mhm what is the
best movie with man in the
title man in the title
Superman Man The Running
Man okay Andy begin I mean it's not even
a fight Superman took com like took the
cheesiness of what the comics were at
the time and made a man fly that's what
the poster said Christopher ree amazing
casting Marlin Brando it's a perfect
film it's so much more iconic than the
running man it's not even a fight well
the question is not which film is more
iic is which one is better Superman has
the dumb twist at the end with turning
time backwards yes it has good actors in
it but the Running Man is so much fun to
watch it's one that I've watched way
more times than Superman it's so
enjoyable you've got the Schwarzenegger
onliners you've got the great villains I
it's a better movie I mean runningman
has so many silly I mean talking about
the world spinning about the the yes
they're fun and in a stupid way Superman
is so much stronger holy
crap Dan I'm sorry you're not even
making it into the speed Andy
get the Ry just cuz it was fun and
you've watched it more does not make it
better than Andy's argument that it's
it's a better overall they're going hate
me they're going to hate me I'm so sorry
guys this is not Revenge I promise May
it's not canon because you're judging
yeah it's not canon put the asteris up
there uh throw the asteris up wow wow
it's been it's been oh sorry buddy uh
it's fine it's like John Cena losing
yeah wa The Undertaker who so saying I
got a chance but yeah I mean uh James
Cameron's
on Simple Jack um
so we don't think that was your I'm very
upset about the Aquaman question still
no Rainman no um no uh Batman are you
taking me to task about not being able
to come with an answer on this no I've
been there I've been there a million
times we all know how it goes those both
way good choices too thank you for
pointing out what I didn't pick I
appreciate that I didn't think of either
of them though I didn't either let's go
to thought was man of the house the
Jonathan Taylor Thomas Cher thinking Man
of Steel was like I did too and I would
have I would have I would have resigned
before I said Man of Steel no Joanna man
all right fine so we're going into the
speed round uh I will enlist uh Dan and
Jason's help if I need it but otherwise
I'll just be making the call let's get
this going first
question better it's neither or better
spoof franchise Naked Gun or Austin
Powers Naked Gun a Powers Andy go gun
just Leslie neelon alone deserves to be
better I mean he defined that that world
of spoof movies to me and then even the
sequels are funnier um Naked Gun has is
that your beaver stuffed I mean I could
go on and on about amazing things but
Austin power says groovy baby it's a
funny character Naked Gun is a far
better funnier movie uh the first dos of
powers is better than any of the Naked
Gun movies the second movie is very
funny we all think about the third movie
yeah that is not as as good but those
that first movie beats anything of the
naked gum movies and don't think about
The Love Guru get that out of your mind
that has nothing to do with Austin
Powers I totally challenge I think the
Naked Gun sequels it's the best spoof
Fran franchise Naked Gun crushes the
Austin power
sequels okay my 5sec re clarify you guys
I was waiting for the Bell way under
time uh okay great um yeah that was
close you both uh really just talked
about um uh you were making a great
point that Austin Powers is just a
character Naked Gun is a whole funny
franchise and he gets the point on that
one oh my God taking the lead
okay still in it next question this is a
broad one best Hollywood Daniel D
Lewis
uh 5
Seconds Daniel
redcliffe Dan I just kind of want to
hear it Andy go ahead need to make the
argument D Lewis is I mean so many
awards I mean he takes himself into
those characters like no other actor
does I mean people just any actor
director looks up to him as the epitome
of when you say an actor it's Daniel de
okay that's crazy Daniel Radcliffe is
Harry Potter it's the most one of the
most iconic characters of all time kids
love him more more kids know him than
Daniel de Lewis okay when you ask a kid
who is this and it's a picture Daniel de
Lewis they go who this is Harry Potter
it's Daniel Radcliffe he's on Broadway
more kids know Lincoln is I don't think
that's
true I you you're right more kids
probably do know Harry Potter than
Abraham Lincoln but your first argument
was too strong Daniel de Lewis and he
gets the point did you see how I sold
that though holy crap moving on EX what
is the best pre- Marvel Cinematic
Universe Marvel movie
pre uh Spider-Man
2 5 Seconds uh Spider-Man 2 is and has 5
Seconds Spider-Man Spider-Man okay uh
Spider-Man 2 is obviously way better
than the Spider-Man uh they actually all
the things came together the effects are
better it's a more emotional the villain
is so much better than def's Green
Goblin the Doc O fight on the train it's
it's a real personal story between the
two of them and most people assume still
think that's the best superher movie of
all
time Spider-Man 1 just created it though
Spider-Man one took so which no one had
really done and made it fun I two has
some dramatic moments but that moment
seeing Spider-Man swing through the
skies really borne the entire franchise
so that alone I think is just you have
to not discredit that and say that it's
better you say it's fun but there's so
many cringe moments in the movie Macy
Gray the PE New York Don't Mess With Us
New York baby I forgot about that
excellent point just swing through the
sky one moment is not enough Spider-Man
2 is a better movie you made better
argument congratulations Mike Carlson
you're still in it still in the game
thank you okay skin of my teeth now this
one is uh a broader one and here we go
what is the best Tom Hanks movie after
the year
2000 Castaway Catch Me If You Can okay
great 2000 fact check those but I think
we're good we 200000 was cast away right
2000 is Cast Away go ahead Andy I mean
cway is showed that we could just watch
him that alone is the reason why it's
it's the best because I mean people came
and saw it multiple times and the movie
is solely Tom Hanks there are no actors
there's so very little actors that could
pull that off and he made you believe it
he made you cry when he loses a
volleyball it's so emotional and such a
perfect Tom GS performance uh great
movie obviously but like it's it's sort
of gimmicky in the sense that like with
just Tom Hanks on an island and and I've
never seen the movie twice I don't want
to watch it twice Catch Me If You Can
it's fun it's it's Spielberg it is Hanks
it is uh DiCaprio walking these
performances are fun it's it moves fast
and it's such an enjoyable movie and
it's the kind of movie we want from Tom
Hanks yeah but Sim Tom hanks's movie
it's Leonardo caprio's movie he's in the
movie this is that's semantics really
all right well Mike you made a good
point that it was fun and it was
enjoyable but nothing beats that Andy
said that it's just Tom Hanks for the
entire movie great Point as I have it
it's 54 Andy so if my calculations are
correct I believe the next question
takes it yes yes they are correct Andy
is in the lead but if Mike gets this we
go into a tiebreaker okay whoa high
stakes huge Stakes who is going to uh
unse the champ but not be the champ but
just be the first person to take down
Dan The Mad Man Merl it all comes down
to this next one or two speed round
questions and the question is oh I love
this one it's broad but what is the
worst Colin Ferell movie Booth I I I
heard you say phone booth what did you
say Daredevil Daredevil uh okay you Andy
you start you said it first oh phone
booth uh is just it's Joel Schumacher as
worst it's him it's the opposite of
Castaway uh where you see you just don't
want to watch him in this movie in a
phone booth it's so stupid it's so silly
and Daredevil well I'll respond to
Daredevil I guess once he says I'll do
my 5c rebuttal uh that movie is
inoffensive to me it's it's silly it's
like I don't really want to watch it but
it's sort of middle of the road
Daredevil is actively offensive it gets
so many things wrong with the source
material things that we love and it's
totally just misses the mark which is
why everybody's so happy now that
there's a TV show because finally we go
oh that's what we all wanted from it
conero wasn't the worst part of that
movie though he was the best part say
worst part of the movie okay wow see
that that is a matter of taste and
you're right that Daredevil it did ruin
an establish thing that people love
whereas phone booth is very easily
avoided and you can just give her take
it Mike gets the point wow oh boy wow
holy
moly wow best Colin Ferell movie as
Daredevil Colin Ferell movie he was the
best part he's been in every Colin
Ferell movie besides bres is the worst
col FAL movie um what besides in bres
what no what no holy crap it's come to
this wow so many tiebreakers so is this
the final whoever wins this thank you
man cam here we go this is a either or
question mhm and it's some deep nerd
stuff all right who wins in a fight
Dumbledore or Gandalf
Dumbledore uh dumb
Gandalf uh Dumbledore is a wizard okay
he is the head of all of the Wizards now
I don't know what age obviously
Dumbledore is dead Gandalf is not that
doesn't matter Dumbledore has all of
these spells all of this at disposal all
of the other wizards look up to him
because he has been the top dog forever
Dumbledore is sort of a nice too nice
Gandalf is I think a little harsher I
would believe he'd actually fist fight
alone Gandalf would take him down and
gandal has Wizards too uh K Blanchett
all his characters all his friends he's
got a bigger crew against him whereas
he's watch kids he's not in the fight
we're talking a fight Gandalf does not
have a spell book which has literally
every spell possible imaginable he is a
he is a he has but he doesn't use them
for bad wow oh my
God yikes so yeah what it comes down to
is you were bringing up fist fights and
his crew and stuff like that and this is
a wizard on Wizard battle and you made
reference to he's a more powerful wizard
which may or may not be true but I
didn't hear why Gandalf Gandalf cannot
be killed um and all this and Dumbledore
that's it I mean don't we know that I
got to say that to you well regardless I
didn't hear in your argument why why who
would win in a wizard battle without
bringing in his he brought he said he
would do bring all the Wizard Academy no
I didn't say the I said he has all the
well that's what I was responding to
we'll go back to the tape Mike Carlson
congratulations yes you take it you
clawed your way back oh man wow wow
congrats brother I'm sweating I'm so so
sorry this has happened to uh speed my
heel to unse Dan Andy I'm sorry you're
still looking for that a friend I mean a
coworker friend didn't take him out Mike
Carlson so you can both be equally
furious at me when we go to work
tomorrow oh my gosh that's it for this
episode woo we're out of time what you
guys think of the
show you watching on YouTube give us a
comment below uh tell us how I did I'm
sorry tell us how we all did Dan you
still rock man you're the champ in my
heart undefeated I mean not undefeated
the champ still the so wow I got to
thank Our Guest for being here Andy
signor at Andy signor still looking to
get that first win but man you're a hard
fighter wow thanks Spencer sorry dude no
it was very fun and I what an honor to
fight against you guys yeah always like
fighting against the best always good
fan favorite Mike Carlson fat Carlson P
Instagram Twitter Periscope Star Wars
card Trader keep trading with me guys a
shout out to all of you some people
wanted me to specifically name them I
can't do it I forget shout out to you
guys
keep swapping those cards and Dan The
Madman Merl still the champ uh put an
asteris on the loss if you want but it's
at Merl Dan on Instagram and Twitter at
Merl Dan and if you agree with me I want
you to go find a poster of Jurassic
world I want you to shout I'm mad as
hell and I'm not going to take this
anymore damn straight and finally can't
forget on The Dan cam on the man cam uh
Jason Inman jawin yep at Jawan on
Twitter Periscope Instagram not Star
Wars battle card card Trader card
traders Ops digital I don't trade cards
but we're all signing up for that and
and finally myself filling in for Andy
first guest uh judge sorry about that or
uh great Spencer okay I did it's tough
you're right Andy it's tough but I'm at
Spencer jgilbert on Instagram on Twitter
on Spencer J gilbert.com which will be
on Squarespace by the time this is up
and that's all the time we had today
we'll see you guys next week
bye-bye every podcast we put on YouTube
comes with this Kick-Ass graphic listing
all the topics your favorite screen
Junkies podcasters are talking about if
you click the topics you can skip around
and choose your own podcast Battle
Royale go ahead try them all if you
haven't already subscribe to screen
chunkies on YouTube to join us for
future fights or if you prefer to listen
on iTunes click the logo to download an
audio
version